dans l'épisode précédent on a parlé du
paradoxe de russell qui est le pire
paradoxe de toute l'histoire de la
logique
en bref ce paradoxe affirme que la
théorie des ensembles de frais lieu que
l'on appelle parfois la théorie des
ensembles naïve est pire que archi
fausse elle est inconsistante
car elle permet la construction d'un
monstre mathématiques l'ensemble de
russell qui se contredit lui même ce
paradoxe a détruit des décennies de
travaux de logicien qui cherchait à
enfin comprendre ce qui était vraiment
la logique
je voulais déjà dit mais il est bon de
le répéter la logique n'a absolument
rien de logique plutôt très souvent
quand on utilise le mot logique on ne
parle pas de la logique on parle plutôt
de ce que l'on pense être du bon sens
mais le bon sens n'est pas forcément
logique et la logique n'est clairement
pas du bon sens si un truc que
j'aimerais que vous reteniez de cette
série sur l'infini c'est que la logique
la vraie logique c'est quelque chose qui
nous est très difficile à comprendre et
qu'il faut vraiment réfléchir et prendre
le temps de penser pour acquérir un sens
logique
aujourd'hui je vais vraiment insister
dessus en vous parlant de 4 paradoxe
apparent de la logique mathématique qui
ont été découverts au début du 20e
siècle
[Musique]
paradoxe 1 le paradoxe du barbier
imaginons que dans une contrée très
lointaine la loi impose aux seuls barbe
et du village de raser tous ceux qui ne
se rase pas eux mêmes questions est ce
que le barbier se rasent lui-même
eh bien s'ils se rasent lui-même alors
le barbier ne peut pas le raset du coup
il ne peut pas se raser lui-même mais à
linverse s'il ne se rase pas lui-même
alors la loi lui impose de se faire
raser par le barbier qui n'est autre que
lui-même
du coup il se raserait lui-même paradoxe
ce paradoxe peut sembler idiot pourtant
remplacé barbier par l'ensemble de
russell dont on a parlé dans l'épisode
précédent et se raser part appartenir à
l'histoire devient alors celle d'un
ensemble qui doit contenir tous les
ensembles qui ne se contiennent pas eux
mêmes comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode
précédent cet ensemble ne peut ni se
contenir ni ne pas à se contenir et ça
c'est a rendu freegun totalement
complètement fou je me permets
d'insister encore un peu plus sur le
paradoxe de russell qui a de très
grandes similarités avec le théorème
d'incomplétude de gödel dont on parlera
dans le prochain épisode
en vous proposant le mini défilé suivant
supposer qu après votre mort vous soyez
confronté à deux portes une porte mène
au paradis l'autre à l'enfer ben vous ne
savez pas laquelle
fort heureusement il y à un ange qui
sait exactement quel porte mène au
paradis qu'elle porte mène à l'enfer et
vous avez le droit de lui poser une
question
sauf que vous savez aussi que cet enjeu
pourrait très bien être un démon qui ne
fait que mentir
l'ange dit toujours la vérité le des
moments toujours vous avez le droit qu'à
une seule question quelle question lui
poser pour savoir quelles portes mais
nous parler qu'elle porte mène à l'enfer
je vous invite comme d'habitude à mettre
aux propositions de réponses dans les
commentaires
et on reviendra dessus dans le prochain
épisode
[Musique]
paradoxe de le paradoxe de berry il
existe des nombres que l'on peut décrire
en très peu de caractère c'est le cas
par exemple d'un google ou du nombre de
grammes de la longueur de la suite de
gauche stein de gras n 19 ou encore du
nombre 150 3252 même si ses membres sont
très grand au point que l'on peut pas
réécrire ses nombres en base décimales
classique dans notre univers il est
quand même possible de définir ces
nombres avec très peu de caractère avec
ils ont moins de 100 caractères
cependant il ya une infinité de nombre
et seulement un nombre fini de façon de
combiner 100 caractères donc forcément
il ya des nombres qui ne peuvent pas
être défini en 100 caractères ou moins
jusque là tout va bien mais là où ça se
corse c'est si on commence à se demander
quel est le plus petit des nombres que
nous ne peut pas écrire en moins de 100
caractères le problème avec ce monde
c'est que justement cette phrase le plus
petit nombre que l'on ne peut pas
définir en moins de 100 caractères
défini bel et bien un nombre et le fait
en moins de 100 caractères le plus petit
nombre qui ne peut pas être défini en
moins de 100 caractères
semble à la fois bien défini et
inconsistant avec sa propre définition
paradoxe pour résoudre ce paradoxe on
nous renvoie en fait un autre
[Musique]
paradoxe 3 le paradoxe de richard en
utilisant la diagonale de kantor dont on
a parlé dans l'épisode précédent
jules richard est allé un petit peu plus
loin que berry en définissant un nombre
qui ne peut pas être défini comme very
richard commence par lister toutes les
définitions de nombreux réel et tous les
nombres réels qui correspondent à ces
définitions et paf on fait un petit coup
de diagonale de kantor on prend tous les
éléments de radier connaît le remplacer
cinq par des héros et tous les autres
chiffres par des 5 ce qui nous donne un
nouveau nombre réel
ce nouveau nombre réel est bien défini
par la construction qu'on en a donné en
un nombre fini de clarac faire pourtant
pas l'argument classique de la diagonale
de kantor on sait aussi que ce nombre ne
peut pas avoir été listés par richard or
la liste de richard était censé contenir
tous les nombres que l'on pouvait
définir grâce à la diagonale de kantor
n'a donc défini un nombre qui ne pouvait
pas être défini paradoxe pour comprendre
les paradoxes de berry et richard il
faut bien se rendre compte qu'à la
manière dont on a parlé des
mathématiques à chaque fois n'utilisez
pas les vrais symboles du langage des
mathématiques et c'est pour ça notamment
que dans l'épisode 13
j'ai vraiment insisté sur l'importance
d'utiliser les symboles mathématiques
pour parler des mathématiques à chaque
fois que l'on fait des mathématiques
sans utiliser ces symboles ont fait en
fait des méta mathématiques c'est à dire
que l'on me tarde prête les
mathématiques
eh bien ce sont ces méta mathématiques
qui ont conduit au paradoxe de berry et
de richard
heureusement les vrais mathématiques
elle reste cohérente
[Musique]
paradoxe 4 le paradoxe de ce col m alors
cela c'est du gros lourd ya trois ans
j'ai écrit un article sur mon blog sur
la constructibilité dénombre verra fin
de l'article j'ai parlé des nombres
définissable j'ai affirmé que l'ensemble
des nombres définissable à l'instar des
nombres rationnelle des nombres
algébrique et dénombre calculable était
un ensemble infinie certes mais un
infini dénombrable c'est ce qu'affirme
et wikipedia est la preuve en est très
simple pour définir un nombre il faut
utiliser les symboles du langage de
l'arithmétique de piano par exemple or
l'ensemble des définitions est un infini
dénombrable puisque l'on peut par
exemple commencer par les définitions
courte
or on a démontré dans l'épisode
précédent que l'ensemble des nombres
réels et indénombrables du coup bah ya
forcément des nombreux et elle qui ne
peuvent pas être défini et même on envie
de dire que la plupart des nombres réels
ne peuvent pas être défini et bien non
je me suis fait rappeler à l'ordre par
un ami logicien puis avec thor bon ça ça
arrive souvent mais wikipédia aussi
avait tort et ça pour le coup surtout m
c'est quand même plus rares ce
qu'affirmait à mon ami logicien c'est
qu'il existe des modèles mathématiques
dans lesquelles tous les nombres réels
sont définissable et on peut en
particulier lister l'ensemble des
nombreux réel c'est ce qu'on appelle le
théorème de l'ohvn heinz koll m ce
théorème dit que toute logique du
premier ordre comme par exemple ait
meetic de p and o dont on a déjà parlé
et l'a théorisé fc dont on parlera
bientôt toutes ces théories
mathématiques communément admise par la
communauté mathématique y compris celles
qu'ils contiennent des infinis très
largement supérieur strictement plus
grand que l'infini dénombrable si ces
théories sont cohérentes
alors elle possède toujours des modèles
dénombrable c'est à dire qu'il existe un
ensemble d'objets mathématiques
dénombrable qui satisfont les actions de
la théorie paradoxe je ne sais pas à
quel point ça va vous satisfaire mais je
vais vous donner l'explication qu'elle
m'avait donné
mon ami logicien une théorie
mathématique c'est un peu comme un sac
de pommes ou chaque pomme est un objet
de la théorie mathématique et puis il ya
des relations entre les pommes par
exemple deux pommes ont la même taille
s'il existe une troisième pomme qui fait
le lien qui montrent qu'elles ont la
même taille 7 plutôt trop comme on
l'appelle souvent une biche section
maintenant d'entre ses conseils qu'il y
à une pomme qui correspond à l'ensemble
des anti naturel et une autre pomme qui
correspond à l'ensemble des nombres
réels bien dire que nombreux real ne
peuvent pas être dénombrées avec les
entier naturel revient à dire qu'il
n'existe pas de troisième pomme qui face
à budget ctions entre ces deux autres
pommes ou plus précisément s'en vient
dire que si on rajouter cette pomme dans
notre sac de pommes alors il se
passerait un cataclysme
à l'intérieur d'autres sacs de pommes
qui ferait de ce sac de pommes un
mauvais sac de pommes et si on y
réfléchit ça veut dire que dire que
l'ensemble des nombre réel est trop
grand pour être listé avec des anti
naturel est un abus de langage des méta
mathématiques une surinterprétation du
théorème de kantor parce que ce que dit
vraiment le théorème de kantor ce n'est
pas que l'un des ensembles est plus
grand que l'autre ce qu'il dit vraiment
c'est que si on supposait qu'il y avait
cette pomme qui faisait 7 liens de
budget ctions entre l'ensemble des
réelles et l'ensemble des nombres
entiers naturels
alors notre sac de pommes sera un
mauvais sac de pommes le théorème de
kantor dit que pour que ce sac de pomme
reste un bon sac de pommes il faut
absolument qu'il n'y ait pas de pommes
qu'ils fassent cette pige action entre
les deux os de pommes et de façon
cruciale si on réfléchit vraiment à tout
cela on se rend compte que ce n'est pas
une question de taille et une fois qu'on
se rend compte que le fait qu'il
n'existe pas cette direction n'est pas
une question de taille
on commence peut-être à comprendre
comment est ce qu'il est possible que
notre sac de pommes contiennent un
infini dénombrable de pomme alors qu'il
est impossible de lister toutes les
pommes de votre sac de pommes avec les
entiers naturels qui sont définies dans
le sac de pommes en fait ce qui se passe
et que nous
qui sommes à l'extérieur du sac de
pommes on est capable de lister les
pommes avec des anti naturel qui ne sont
pas à l'intérieur du sac de pommes alors
vous allez sans doute envie de dire que
tout ce que je viens de raconter n'est
absolument pas logique
et là j'ai envie de vous rétorquer que
je trouve ça presque logique que vous
trouviez que la logique ne soit pas
logique
mais je vous le garantis le problème ne
vient pas de la logique
elle vient de ce que l'on croît être
logique
la dernière fois on a parlé de la
diagonale dévastatrice de canto a et on
a notamment prouvé qu'il n'y avait pas
de plus grande un fini et ça fait réagir
notamment gaël bxl qui se demandaient
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut utiliser a
déconné le compteur pour montrer qu'ils
avaient deux pas de plus grand infinie
pourquoi ce n'était pas juste de
rajouter un nouvel élément dans un
ensemble et cette fois ça faisait
ensemble plus grand bien de remarques à
faire à cela c'est qu'a priori ils
ensemble de tous les ensembles et pays
contient déjà tout du coup on peut rien
lui rajouter mais bon ça c'est un
argument à deux balles puisque
l'ensemble de tous ensemble n'existe pas
le vrai argument a rétorqué à la
remarque de gueule bxl l'asse selon les
superbes vidéos qu'on fait une vigilance
étonnante
en fait j'ai un petit peu supposée dans
les vidéos précédentes que vous aviez un
petit peu vu ces vidéos en tout cas
entendu parler des choses qui sont ces
vidéos en tout cas je vous recommande
très fortement d'aller voir ces vidéos
si vous n'êtes pas compris mon épisode
précédent
je vais pas répéter ce qui avait été
déjà très bien expliqué dans ces deux
vidéos sons sigh que
elle est un petit peu plus vite gail bxl
demande aussi s'il accepte de fondations
n'empêcherait pas justement le paradoxe
de russell m1 faut bien se rendre compte
que l'action de fondation a été inventé
en réaction aux paradoxes de russell qui
n'apparaissait pas dans la théorie de
fraigneau et qu'il était il a été
rajouté pour empêcher des paradoxes à
larsson ceci étant dit la maxime de
fondations c'est le plus pourri de tous
les axiomes issa absolument à rien vous
pouvez l'enlever de joseph désiré c'est
tout ce que vous voulez ça ne changera
rien du tout aux mathématiques mais pour
mieux comprendre pourquoi est-ce que
vous rejette aussi violemment
l'axiome de fondations je dis pas qu'il
faut je dis juste qu'il sert à ça sera
plus clair quand on aura parlé du
théorème d'incomplétude de gödel et des
maths constructiviste vous avez été
nombreux à réagir à l'ensemble des
animaux et notamment à cette figure là
que j'ai misé un moment dans la vidéo
précédente où on a l'impression que
l'ensemble des animaux et du coup risqué
et je le trouve ça vraiment génial de
voir votre perspicacité de voir qu'ils
avaient réagi
cette mauvaise représentation de
l'ensemble des animaux qui pourraient
pas être listées à priori ceci dit il ya
deux réactions possibles c'est la
première c'est qu'en fait cette
représentation c'est une représentation
géométrique un truc c'est comme lorsque
j'apprenais à faire des cercles à
l'école je faisais jamais au combat où
il s'était toujours pourri mais descend
jusqu'à proxima tiff ses dessins
approximatif sont utiles pour raisonner
est ce qu'ils vont faire après c'est la
preuve que l'on écrit à preuve formelle
que l'on écrit et qui s'inspire de ses
dessins la faire des dessins faut c'est
pas grave c est ce qu on fait beaucoup
en mathématiques ci compte c'est la
preuve formelle que
après et dans ce cas si vous écrivez la
preuve formelle qui correspond à ce
dessin vous obtenez un truc qui est
parfaitement valable pour n'importe quel
ensemble quelle que soit sa qualité
la deuxième réaction que je pourrais
avoir à ce genre de commentaire c'est
qui en fait il est possible de lister
n'importe quel ensemble si on à l'action
du choix en fait la crème du choix nous
dit justement que tout ensemble
peut-être listés mais avec des listes
qui sont pas forcément uniquement
restreinte aux nombres entiers naturels
avec des listes qui peuvent être
transmis notamment et notamment bonjour
envoie sur l'épisode sur le thème du
flou
j'avais parlé de lister l'ensemble des
nombreux réel qui ce qui peut être fait
avec la cime du choix même si l'un des
side habité d'une prothèse du continu
garantit le fait que mme on ne sait pas
comment faire qu'on ne peut pas savoir
comment faire des jam réagi au fait qu'
il existe des ensembles qu'on ne peut
pas construire est ce que lorsqu en
classe on nous dit soit eux l'ensemble
des fonctions de maire dans les arts
continue wever est ce que lorsqu'on
écrit des trucs comme ça n'a le droit de
les écrire vraiment ça c'est une
question absolument fascinante et c'est
exactement ce genre de question que je
veux que vous posiez donc non d'un jam
tu n'es pas fou à lier tu es pire que ça
tue les deux nuls mathématicien en fait
la recherche sur les fondations
mathématiques de russell frais que quand
tu auras tout ça consistait justement
essayer de prouver qu'on avait le droit
de parler de l'ensemble eu des fonctions
continue de faire briller sous le nom
joueur est toute la difficulté était là
parce que c'était pas facile c'est pas
un exercice facile et la fin de cette
série sur infinie va beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup parlé de ce genre de problème
justement enfin maisterra michael james
hayes 2 maximax nous font la remarque
que dans le cas de ma preuve avec la
diagonale de kantor que l'ensemble des
réelles ne peuvent pas être des nombreux
boss 2 en fait il y avait un problème
dans cette preuve parce qu'il ya des
nombres qui ont plusieurs écriture et
d'en parler dans l'épisode 2 2 sur le
fait que 0,9 et est liée à l' inde donc
de la même façon 0,1 0,1 0,1
et en fait la même chose que 0,1 0,1 1
000 et donc ça semble être une faille
dans la preuve que l'ensemble de nos
progrès mais pas des non braves alors ce
qu'ils n'ont pas eue c'est que en fait
dans me en fait je crois qu'ils ont
raison merde je vous ai raconté de la
grosse merde dans l'épisode précédent
hier que l'on sent les nombreux elle est
en effet non des noix me mets à preuve
nous est donnée complètement fou ce
schéma du coup je vous encourage à aller
voir les vidéos des ligier sur cette
zone qui n'ont pas fait de la merde dans
la démonstration que l'ensemble des
nombreux n est pas dénombrable il en
profite aussi pour saluer tous ceux qui
mettent des commentaires absolument
géniaux en bas de mes vidéos là
notamment deux maximax et mr michael
dreams merci beaucoup pour tous les
messages que vous mettez clarifier les
questions des uns et des autres et puis
aussi les uns et les autres
quand vous voyez des messages de
maximiles l'histoire american greetings
quelques autres donc ils viennent ces
ruines ou ou marjorie et jesse qui ont
laissé énormément de commentaires de
très très bonne qualité de réponse à
chaque fois merci beaucoup et puis les
autres fait confiance à leurs
commentaires ils disent des trucs très
très intelligent je pense que cinq faux
rôle peut se vanter d'avoir les
meilleurs commentateurs ou par minsk est
les meilleurs commentateurs de tout
youtube et j'espère que j'avais mais cet
épisode la prochaine fois on va parler
du théorème sur le plus mythique le plus
fou de toute l'histoire des
mathématiques à savoir le théorème
d'incomplétude tollé théorème
d'incomplétude de gueule si vous avez
aimé cet épisode penser à le lac et à le
commenter à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pour notamment chez les futurs
deux épisodes d'une heure ci est hyper
fort dont et j'espère que je verrai la
prochaine fois
cette phrase est fausse quand on y
réfléchit si cette phrase est
effectivement fausses
alors allez vrai mais si on admet que
cette phrase est vraie elle devient fos
le plus petites antilles qu'on ne peut
pas définir en français avec une phrase
de moine ni caractère et on vient
pourtant de le faire dans à peine 140